[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online ladies Nick it's a final rose
tonight Chris Harrison took to Instagram
to share an epic throwback with the
first-ever bachelor Alex Michelle as the
franchise celebrated 15 years on
television on Saturday oh my gosh you're
so excited Reese Witherspoon posted this
sweet pic with husband jim toth to
twitter in celebration of their sixth
wedding anniversary Kristin Cavallari
showed off her bikini bod while on vacay
with husband jay cutler setting the
record straight she is not pregnant with
baby number four after fans speculated
she may be holding a bump in this cute
snap she explained in the caption quote
win was blowing and I was trying to hold
down my romper I just think I've worked
too hard I have to rest stranger things
star Millie Bobby Brown posted that
apology video after having to cancel her
collective Cana parents first time
riding on your own home David Beckham
shared that adorable clip of his
five-year-old daughter Harper riding her
bike for the first time captioning it so
so proud ariana grande shared too cute
throwback pics from her childhood
getting a haircut and this foreshadowing
snap playing with a guitar meanwhile
louis Tomlinson wished his late mother a
happy birthday on Twitter writing I love
you
you